Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to What to Say!
Do you know what to say when you want to show interest?
Listen out for useful language for showing interest.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Morning, Bob.
Ah, good morning.
It's so rainy today.
The weather in this country is horrible!
Yes ...
yes ...
The weather was even worse when I lived in Canada.
Oh, I didn't know that you lived in Canada, Bob.
How cool!
One winter
it was so cold and windy
that I fell on the ice
and broke my leg in three places.
Oh no! You're joking!
I wish I was, Noelia,
I wish I was.
I was never the same after that winter.
And my leg is still bad today.
Really?
I'm sorry to hear that.
Poor you.
But it's not all bad.
I met my wife in the hospital.
She was the doctor who looked at my leg!
No way!
It was love at first sight!
Ah, that's brilliant!
Yes, and we're still in love 40 years later ...
So in the end,
breaking your leg was the best thing that could have happened.
Yes,
I suppose it was!
Hello again!
Aww, I love a story with a happy ending!
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for showing interest?
Listen to me and then repeat.
Oh, I didn't know that you lived in Canada!
How cool!
Oh no, poor you.
You're joking!
Really?
I'm sorry to hear that.
No way!
That's brilliant!
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you want to show interest in English.
Bye for now!